Uh [Music] I got a bar line for the 1st time. Now,
I also have a
center cow
. Yes, I had a monitor for each.
Also the medicine. Oh, the see. Yeah
[Music]
U
[Music] I
know about it  Incarnation is
yes again
Soyo and Sentence 2
Attempts n I've been hitel ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah go
out of the memory
When I came to eat, I came to eat, and when I was eating, I was a
generous child in Inhyeon-dong. Yes, it was
ridiculous. Farmhouse, weak mountain, Lord God
.
[Music] I
usually change to a Lucida, walk to the walkway, walk to the
godmother, ask for a godmother, say something strange about the effect,
I love
it, I have a hard time with it,
or
it’s over.
Oh,
I said I couldn’t do it too well, so I followed this
and
I’m so sully, Eric, why go out, why do I get out, why do I have to go out?
Is it a popular movie? It's said that
you can't have a sound.
But in
summary, sweat
or a tool tickle me,
but I have to pull
it out.